so this first property you bought for
317 rented on Airbnb making a load of
money went up in value pulled the equity
out taxfree if I want something I get it
my dream now is property I can just see
the zeros what did you say your Revenue
was last year
17070 Grand they have to have five star
reviews to be in my property worst thing
than not having a tenant is a bad tenant
and when you've gone through the crap
I've gone through you never want that
again
tonight we have a very special guest and
this is going to be interesting because
uh I've never done this before but I'm
going to be interviewing somebody about
their success and we're going to film
this and this is going to be the very
first live winners on a Wednesday the
guest that I have lined up to come and
speak is going to
be one of you
guys oh oh
what does that mean that means if no one
volunteers I will have nobody to
interview we've already got one
volunteer we've already got another
we've already got another we've got
another got another all right good I'm
going to ask each person to come on
stage in a minute and just give a quick
30 to 60 second snapshot of what you've
done what your successes are and then
once everyone shared we're going to all
have a Cher each and whoever gets the
loudest chair we'll do live right now so
comeing at the side of the stage come
come come let's show some luck to
Muhammed wait hello everyone obviously I
moved to the UK when I was 15 years old
I never been to school from selling
walnuts in streets of Iran to balloons
and now I'm making about 15 to 20 grand
a month three times I went down the hill
and that was because of gambling
Direction I learned a big lesson join
the academy with my own money and
everything and I think I deserve well
more than that I
will it's
you
hey hey guys started Academy just two
months ago I came into the academy
thinking I don't want to deal Source I
don't want to sell anything I just want
to do BRS and just find my own deals and
I'm getting offered all these offers
from State agents that are already
managing my properties I got a block of
21 Flats coming up soon in Angel
Islington and the other state agent I
got he's says he's got a block of 27
flats and I was like I don't know what
to do with this stuff I just went to buy
properties and refer them and turn them
into flats and then suddenly I'm like
getting all these rent to rent deals
when they're finished I'll bring to the
academy all you guys could just tear it
apart right all
right well done C uh last we've got n so
come on N just make some noise
n hi uh NJ Bueno been in London 22 years
came here 18 grew myself into the
corporate world for Something Completely
non-proper property related bought a
couple of properties while I was doing
that turned them to into essay for the
last 8 years averaged me about eight
grand profit a month last year I made a
180 Grand revenue on those two
properties so as we said what's going to
happen is now I'm going to give a shout
out to each one and then we're going to
decide which one we're going to
interview live now all incredible and
interesting and quirky and different so
make some noise for
[Music]
Muhammad okay make some noise for
Q and make some noise for
NJ I think it was very similar but I
think maybe NJ just about NJ come join
me on the stage Make some noise for
n welcome to Winners honor Wednesday
live where every single Wednesday I
interview a success student from the
academy who's absolutely smashed it in
property but also got an interesting
story so this week we've got Nar she's
going to be sharing her story she's all
the way from Brazil so please welcome
Nar well firstly thank thank you so much
for joining us at winners on a Wednesday
live yeah last uh surprised right yeah
well thank you so much so you've got an
interesting back story you're killing it
in property what did you say your
Revenue was last year in property um
between two properties it was about 170
170 Grand Revenue what about profit
profit would be uh about 60% of that the
interesting thing with that is people
that want to make six figures in
property they might think they've got to
own loads and loads of properties but
you've managed to achieve that with just
two properties so I'm excited to delve
in into how you've done that how you
financed it and I know you used the
equity from one to get the other so we
want to really learn and understand that
but first you tell us a bit about your
backstory where are you from how did you
get interested in business and what's
your backstory so Brazilian originally I
moved to America my parents immigrated
to America when I was five I grew up
there till I was 15 moved back to Brazil
did High School there but the culture
you know growing up in America Brazilian
culture was very hard as a teenager and
uh I decided to immigrate to London
worked bars clubs did that for a while
legalized myself uh and then went into
um something I'd never heard of in my
life which was litigation support um I
did that for 10 years I started off as a
bde and then ended a shareholder
managing director of our office office
in Dubai I led doing it loved it thrived
in it but in the end I was like I need
to do something else then I took a
well-deserved break travel the world for
a little bit unfortunately then my
father got ill so I went to Brazil
looked after him he lost his battle to
cancer unfortunately last year and then
I was like well I want to go back to
London and I already had the two
properties here so I bought them um one
in 2013 and then the other one a couple
years after that just by remodeling
releasing Equity used that as a deposit
bought the second property gave it to
somebody else I wanted always to set it
up for Airbnb because all through my
business travel I always stayed in
airbnbs so it was almost like a lesson
not knowing just learning what was good
about some not good so good about others
then when I came back from Dubai I took
the Reigns of the Airbnb myself decided
to set up the cleaning the laundry um
and I just manage it on my own like yeah
two properties it's doable how many
reviews have you had over those two
properties out of well the ones that
have left reviews along for a period of
time I never even asked people to leave
reviews and pretty much none myself it's
280 reviews I think and what what rating
do you have a 4.81 rating no bad no bad
very
good so moving forward in your property
business then is service accommodation
short stet AB is that the Golden Nugget
is that the thing or well it is and it
isn't it's great for cash flow so if I
can pick up a few more in London you're
already utilizing my own setup you know
cleaners and laundry and stuff so it' be
pretty simple but it's really brr since
I've been here like on W on on Tuesday I
realized that's what I want to do now
you're on the academy yeah what was it
that made you enroll onto the academy
you've already had two very successful
properties that are bringing in six
figures a year what what was it that
made you want to join to be honest with
you I signed up yesterday after your you
know whole arrow thing and I Wasing and
aing about it even though I could see
the sense of community and all of that
kind of stuff um but I kind of started
to realize that how much you have on tap
and I know how much that stuff costs
right so that alone what do you mean on
tap contractor advice solicitors tax um
all the mentors that have their
different experiences What in in
different areas potential investors to
go in on code deals like you can't you
know you've taken years to build up this
you know uh contact list yes and you're
just tapping into it you know 10 grand
12 Grand just seems not like a lot of
money for it you know yeah so your first
property you bought it in 2013 13 how
much you pay for it
317500 and how much did you have to put
down you remember as a deposit yep 10%
okay so you only put on 31 Grand yep
hold on this is what blows my brain
now so you put down 31 Grand yeah which
bought you a property for 317 Grand now
I bet it's worth more than that it's
worth over 500 over 500 not to mention
the revenue I've made over the last
eight years you know roughly how much
that will be oh I can't I can't work it
out probably more than the property's
worth probably if not well not worth now
but maybe worth then yeah when you
bought it yeah and the second property
tell me about this cuz a lot of people
have got a property yeah they bought it
years ago
bought it put AIT down it goes up in
value and in their mind they're thinking
I want to pay off the mortgage no right
no rich people have debt okay tell me
about that I actually have quite a bit
of equity in it but I have it because I
don't know yet what I'm going to do with
it not because I'm not going to take it
out bad debt good debt right um I'll be
making the same amount up well interest
rates going up I'll be making very close
to what I make Now by releasing hundreds
of thousands of pounds of equity cuz the
mortgage is only going to go up so much
and even if it covers just covers my my
mortgage which it it won't I have this
bundle of cash to go and do things that
are going to make me a ton more money
but when you pull that cash out and you
pull out hundreds of thousands of pounds
which you can then reinvest when you get
in that chunk of cash are you paying tax
on that no you don't pay tax on debt
she's good she's good she's good she's
good
right so tell me some of the challenges
that you've had being in overseas going
to Dubai America Brazil and and you've
now been in the in the property business
for over a decade think about some of
the challenges that you face with like
managing the properties Airbnb and some
of the things that you would love to say
to your 10y year younger s to save the
problems I'm sure there's been a lot of
challenges yeah I mean obviously you got
to learn from your mistakes if you don't
have guid right uh for example not
vetting properly yes you know now I have
a whole vetting system sometimes I turn
down more than what does that look like
tell me about the vetting system five
star reviews on them oh for sure I think
all tenants you should be able to leave
them bad reviews no no no no no they
have to have five star reviews to be in
my
property
what wow really yeah I don't want
parties I mean you should see my flat it
welcomes a party like already here right
if I put a sign over it I have neighbors
it's in a private block how many how
many five star like if they' had one
rating and said five star is that enough
or how many um it really depends on the
booking itself for example I don't take
anything less than three nights and
that's only if it's to fill gaps it's a
minimum of five nights
day what what why is that why do you I
mean it works really well and I'm asking
also for the viewer because they might
be thinking why would you turn down
bookings if someone wants to book for a
night or two nights night why are you
turning them down most likely parties
yeah uh two nights are okay during the
week kind of a Monday or a Sunday to
Thursday situation Thursday Friday
Saturday never right no it's just you
know even in my smaller apartment I
don't do it yeah like your mom said
yesterday the best the worst thing than
have not having a tenant is a bad tenant
and when you've gone through the crap
I've gone through yes you never want
that again and presumably this stuff
that you're saying is stuff that you've
learned over the years oh and the hard
right right and that's why people
watching this now can benefit so much
from from your experience so the tenant
or the guest I should say has to have
five star reviews minimum night stay of
three nights but sometimes five nights
depending on the week what else do you
get their photo ID and stuff um if I've
gone privately or let's say they've G
done a very long booking yes I do yes
because you know if they've booked I've
got someone in there for 84 nights now
then they can like stay another 884
nights yeah and they're paying how much
a night
uh it averages out about 10 and a half
Grand a month and that's with a discount
a monthly discount jeez I had one I had
one booking last hang on a minute no no
no hang on so you bought a property for
317 Grand no no this is the other
property oh the other one well the other
one too gets long bookings and that's
about summer five grand a month uh 4 and
a half Grand uh during the other times
of the year so so this first prop you
bought for 3177 rented it on Airbnb
making a load of money went up in value
made a load of money pulled the equity
out taxfree by refinancing it cuz if
you'd have sold that property then you
might have had to pay a load of tax
loads refinanced it bought another
property what was the second property
you bought uh in shortage three-bedroom
1500 square foot Warehouse e type one
bathro hosted it for a while then I
realized that the questions were coming
in like one bathroom you can you know
you can sleep up to eight people which
also I don't
recommend um and then I went okay screw
it tore the whole thing down refurbished
the whole thing made it like Chef's
kisses and added an on Suite another
bathroom cost me a lot but I've made it
back like yeah I think probably is a
great investment and I obviously
increased the value of the property how
much you paid for it the second one uh
820 820 820 Grand and did you just buy
it with the money that you pulled out of
the prop no I think I had to put in for
the stamp Duty cuz it was a higher
percentage 3% at the time um it wasn't
much I didn't have to put much more into
it you to just slightly top it up yeah I
got I got you make your own luck but you
know I bought it I bought the first
property in 2013 and that year alone my
property in Kings Cross had a 20 23%
increase in value so I sucked it out
straight away yeah and uh left 25% there
and uh took the rest out so you bought
it for 8 20 20 what's it worth now
1.35 so question where else can you make
half a million pounds uplift like just
on one property that that that that's
incredible there's very few businesses
where you can make half a million I mean
how much do you have to spend on it
though about 100 Grand but it was in
2018 so I had 3 years yeah running as it
was I mean I beautifully decorated I
spent about 10 grand yeah yes when I
bought it yes uh and that that was great
for a while but I wanted to double it so
I did I double it so what do you are you
are you now do you have a job now are
you full-time in property I don't have a
job what do you do I refurbish Furniture
I go for walks in the
[Laughter]
forest
yeah
so how how long have you been taking
walks in the for forest and chilling out
traveling like how long has that
lifestyle been the case long enough to
be bored right yeah right it's
interesting that because I think that
when you're making you know the kind of
money you're making which is a really I
mean if if you're a doctor right and
you're working 72 hours a week you don't
make half of that no you don't make half
what you're making so you're making
double the salary you're making as much
money as a doctor and a brain surgeon
who are married and I didn't go to
university right not there's anything
wrong with University it just wasn't for
me it didn't work for my brain but the
interesting thing is though when you've
got passive income coming in it is it is
a bit like well what next so what is it
that drives you now what's what what's
the goal now well I uh made some
Investments pre pandemic not that they
were bad Investments but they didn't
hold out what did you in uh Tech startup
okay that's a RIS startups is risky High
reward but high risk yeah super high
risk I mean they haven't like none of
them have flopped uh you know but I'm
like already preparing myself for the
potentiality of it for the not that I
think about that they're going to
succeed they'll make me Millions okay
amen I believe
it what of all the investments just Tech
startups as property property's always
been the best you reckon 100% it's brick
and mortar yes you can't go wrong with
brick and mortar what's the plan now
with property how are you going to now
go from a financially free bored lady
wandering around in the forest in
investing in Tech startups like what's
the plan now and why is it the plan what
drives you well the plan was to do
increase the service accommodation
however since being here I'm like brr
right you know that makes sense for me
now like I just refurbished
myself um my first apartment so I'm like
I love that whole construction side of
things so if I can buy add value
refinance essay it or HMO it yeah
take my money back put into the next one
right recycle your cash recycle the cash
yes and you know if it is a big enough
deal maybe like partner up with somebody
to you know tell me about mentality okay
for a minute because I think winning in
business winning in property winning in
life just in general a lot of it is your
mentality yes it's knowledge is
important but it's about having the
right attitude and perspective to
business what would you say are the key
differences between having a winning and
a losing
mentality positivity
yeah I think uh thinking of yourself
already in abundance I do obviously as
you should worry about how much things
cost you know but if I want something I
get it because I've worked hard for it I
had my first job when I was 12 you know
I love it I've always wanted to be an
international business woman I did that
you know cuz that was the dream yeah my
dream now is just like property you know
I can just see the zeros you
know yeah you know and I don't I'm not
you know I'm not a fancy person you know
it's not about having things to show off
you know it's really about succeeding in
myself right that's what it is you know
and I believe in the Law of Attraction
you know even little things like someone
asked how your day was if you say not so
bad bad is a negative word you know so
just literally seeing it and believing
in it that's how I did so good in
corporate you know like I didn't know
what the hell litigation support was and
I built like a multi-million pound
portfolio for my company that was a
startup you know yeah what's the
strongest reason why then what's the
thing that gets you out of bed and gets
you excited well I'm still 40 years
young and you know I've tasted the
retirement situation it's great you know
but there's a reason why they say when
like people retire they tend to you know
yeah um it's like when they say when
someone loses a Lo loved one in old age
and they've been together their entire
lives they tend to deteriorate I don't
want to deteriorate you know I want
routine gym you know having fun with the
family you know and speaking to people
you know Community Helping I've always
been interested in helping people you
know if you ask all my friends it's like
n what I do about this I mean if I don't
know I don't know but if I do I was giv
advice to the Uber driver the other day
you know um so I think just really
positive just believe even and just see
it you know just see it seeing is
halfway of your of your journey if you
can see it in your mind you can hold it
in your hands right right that's
powerful stuff that's powerful
stuff
question how how did we me how did you
come across my company I saw you on
Instagram okay and I actually messaged
you um a couple years back on my
birthday and you replied I don't know if
it was you I don't if you control your
Instagram but you replied and I told you
my brief story you know I S my father's
ill you know but I do have intentions to
come to London and when I come I want to
do your course and here we are I follow
you you crazy stuff that you do all over
the place
walking walking around naked in London
I'm like what's this guy doing was that
what attracted you to the
uh hand on heart it was I love that
stuff I work in sales I know what it
takes to bring yourself back up after so
many knockdowns you know and just seeing
you do that I was like this guy is like
balls to the wall does not give a f
about anything you know and and a lot of
people may think oh it's because you're
already succeeded and I don't think it's
about that I'm already succeeded I could
live my life the way I live it now and
you know fill my days with I don't know
refurbishing furniture or whatever and
it's great and I'll do that because I
love it um but if you're not
constantly proud of yourself
yeah it can bring you down and if you
can be proud of yourself you have to be
doing things to be proud of yourself you
know that pride of what you did 5 years
ago eventually wears off you know so you
have to keep on the move it's good for
your health it's good for everything
yeah so um you've been following me for
years you've done a bit of training but
you recently made the decision to enroll
onto the academy yeah yesterday
yesterday congratulations with your mate
Tony
congratulations I know it's only a day
in normally I interview people that have
been on the academy six 12 months and
then they share the story but as you had
such a great story already I thought
you'd be able to benefit and and help
people but I been a day what's happened
so far how's your experience been well I
mean literally I did today what I've
been arming and eyeing about doing all
year the rents in London have gone like
that so there's a stress rate for sa you
know that you're like why you know I'm
making at the I'm making you know I'm
like oh you know like can I copy that
but I literally jumped I picked you know
the area I jumped on some calls today
and I got two yeses and at the end this
lady was like well I've got all this
property and like Essex and Chels and
I'm like well it's a little outside my
patch but I'm like yeah I'm happy to see
him if I can work with her and she can
give me all the stuff she's got here
then happy to or I just take on a new
patch yeah absolutely well I'm really
excited about the coming months and
years to see your journey it's been
incredible chatting with you hasn't she
been amazing
guys this is nerve-wracking by the way
well you're doing great what would be
your final piece of advice to someone
listening to this that's thinking about
getting started in business or in
property I think that you know it's like
what you've been saying you have to
invest in yourself you know and it was
my my man over there what's your name
uch yesterday and he just spoke so
positively and I was on the fence I'm
just listening to this guy and I'm like
dude you're so right you're like you are
saying My Philosophy what am I holding
on to you know but just what the academy
from what I seen has to
offer you can't pay for that it will
whatever you do you're going to pay way
more out in the real world for the
things that yeah is here not not even if
you paid you could get it yeah so you
know and the community the motivation
just this alone you know it it's just do
it basically what's your Instagram in
case people want to follow you and
connect with you oh I don't have a
business Instagram you don't you don't
have an in Oh by the time this comes
out you you're going to have a proper
Instagram maybe even a website and I'll
put my last name is Bueno okay so
probably something at like at Bueno
property we'll find it we'll put it in
the description massive shout out to the
guys well who what who did you say it
was uch uch love uch Anna Tony Anna
love we're in a room full of wonderful
Academy
members and it is been a pleasure
working with you this week and a
pleasure to know you pleas you too Sam
it's
[Applause]
no